I've got a leadership
situation I need help with.
I was promoted to a troop commander
position over a fellow team leader who now
reports to me. He has many years of
experience and a lot of knowledge.
He's very,
he's very bitter and not getting the
promotion at not getting the promotion and
is letting me know when I include him in
decision making for the troop or try to
tap into his knowledge and
experience. He, he shuts down,
refuses to give input and says that
I should already have the answers.
Since I'm the troop commander,
I know the troop would benefit from his
input and team dynamics would be much
improved if it wasn't so negative.
I've tried to let him know that
I value, I value his experience.
I feel that his input would be beneficial
and that his negative attitude and
bearing and bearing are not acceptable.
It is making him very
ineffective team leader, I'm,
I'm failing at getting through
to him and I don't want, fuck,
I don't want to fire him for his position.
How can I get him to value
his own position in the
troop and become effective?
Again,
I actually think you're doing the right
thing and you've opened the door for
him. So I think that's a
good first initial approach.
But obviously it doesn't
seem to be working.
Now a couple of different courses
of actions you could take.
One of the things you could do is actually
give them some higher responsibility,
right? Getting put his team in charge,
put him in charge of the whole team.
Sometimes maybe he will step up and start
to lead and see that he's now able to
prove and that you have a lot of
trust in him and all that stuff.
There's also a chance, think about this.
There's also a chance that you might
be coming off as condescending to him.
So imagine this, hey, I go, I
value your experience. Oh No.
Right now, you know, the troop would
really benefit from your input. It's,
it's like you're treating him like
he's a kid and he's getting that.
Those can come off as condescending.
So we have to put those a
little bit in check as well.
And I think those are a little
bit, you know, you put the,
put the person in charge,
you try that you've opened up to try and
get their input and get them involved.
But it's, it might be coming,
it might be coming across as
condescending even if it's,
even if you're doing it, even
if you're just saying, hey man,
could really use your input
on this thing, it'd be great.
Even if you're doing it in like a cool
way in your mind, you might be hearing,
oh, I could really use your help. So even
if you're saying it in a perfect way,
it still might be hitting his ears
in a different way. So I don't know.
At this point, I think when I would
do is I would maybe just back off,
I would just go forward, uh,
treating him like one of the leaders
and expect him to perform as you expect
your leaders to perform. I
think you've made the effort,
it didn't really work and now you have a
job to do and you've got to get on with
it. There's also, you know,
the world doesn't revolve around his
pouting and his being negative and,
and you, you can't let that
happen. Now on top of that,
this guy's a powder and
he's a negative guy.
That's probably the reason he
didn't get selected to be promoted.
What we talked about
earlier, that boss saw that,
that he saw something along the way
where things didn't go his way and he,
and he pounded into his negative and
that's why he didn't get promoted.
Meanwhile, the guy that did get
promoted when things didn't go his way,
he's like, okay, cool.
Well we'll drive on with what the new
plan is and that's why you got promoted.
So I would say, move on, do your job.
Treat him like you would
treat one of your leaders.
I be very careful that you don't
over-correct because you hear me say like,
okay, I'm gonna treat him normal.
Now all of a sudden you're treating
them like crap. Don't do that.
But treat him as firmly and as fairly
as you would any one of your subordinate
leaders. And we have to see
where it goes from there.
He may end up just not being able
to deal with this fact. I mean,
there's, there's a reason why some people
get promoted and some people don't.
And maybe he's one of these
people that can't humble himself,
which is one of our biggest fears in
somebody that's trying to be a leader is
that they can't humble themselves.
And if that's what's going on,
he's going to have a long, hard road.
And you know whose
fault it is going to be?
Never his never going to be his fault.
It's everyone else's fault. And,
and that's, that'll be problematic.